thank you everyone for being here thank
you all for coming tonight
they said my name is Emma kargh and I am
a senior Hillsdale College speaker
tonight is David Hasani he's a senior
editor Federalist the author of three
books the people have spoken and they
are wrong the case against democracy
Obama's four horsemen the disasters
unleashed by obama's reelection and
nanny-state how food fascists
teetotaling do-gooders priggish
moralists and other boneheaded
bureaucrats are turning America into a
nation of children his lady's book first
freedom a ride through America's
enduring history with the gun discusses
the importance of firearms in America's
past and how they are an important part
for our future please welcome David
Harris Annie
hi there thank you before I start on my
political rant I just wanted to quickly
say that my book first freedom despite
what you heard the other books I've
written were obviously very political
this one is actually or I meant it to be
an accessible history about the gun I
spent I grew up in New York City on the
East Coast I didn't grow up in God and
culture I grew up it and what you would
consider the opposite of gun culture you
know a place where criminals only have
guns and I was always very curious about
why people acted the way they did
towards their weapons why people bought
ar-15 is why the NRA existed and so
forth so that was the impetus for the
book and the reason I wrote it and
because it was a book that I couldn't
find an accessible history on the whole
the whole sort of genre of gun ownership
so but what happened was when I wrote
the book I realized that the history was
the best argument for the Second
Amendment it is the best argument for
the Second Amendment and even a lot of
gun owners and sort of partisans were
very ideological pop guns didn't
understand I think the history part of
the reason for that was that there has
been a 50-year effort legal cultural
political ideological effort to revise
history through you know revisionists
have been revising the history of the
gun for 50 years at least when you read
a book about the revolution and I have
many examples of this written down
somewhere they don't even mention
muskets they don't even mention really
that at Lexington and Concord for
instance that the the men who stood
against the best trained army in the
world were protecting a cache of weapons
not worrying about income inequality or
some other issue that that people think
are important few of any of the
historians who talk about the the 18th
19th century mentioned some of the
greatest American engineers and
businessmen who ever existed Sam colt
you know all the way to Eugene stoner
and in between you know John Browning
they don't even mention it even worse
and we've seen this happen many times
historians embark on an effort to revise
history in a way that that makes it seem
like guns weren't important to the
people and a practical sense either that
they didn't really own them all of this
is is a fantasy
just today I wrote a piece on responding
to Nicholas Nicholas Kristof's piece in
The New York Times called it's time to
speak it's time to it's time to talk
about the NRA and we never talk about
the NRA it's definitely time we started
talking about them so shoehorn them into
the conversation somehow and he got so
much of the history wrong he had he
peddled so many of the myths that that I
found in the you know that I found
through my research for this book my two
years of research for this book all
culminating of course in a collective
right theory of guns that it's not an
individual right but the fact is that
the the that individual ownership was so
omnipresent in the colonies before the
Revolution going even farther back that
it wasn't even a debatable point the
Minutemen never ever were told that they
had to return their muskets after firing
at the British obviously the Revolution
would have been short-lived the debate
over the Second Amendment regarding the
Second Amendment during the writing of
the Constitution was merely about
whether the states or the federal
government would control the militias it
wasn't a bad individual ownership
there's not a single quote that can be
found by any founder that anyone has
proof provided not another revisionist
historians that says that that shows
that any founder didn't intend
individuals to own guns from military
leaders to the to the intellectual
leaders to the religious leaders which I
detail on the book all of them believed
in the individual's right to
self-defense not just as a collective
but as an individual and it's not
surprising of course because the right
to self-defense goes back farther in
English common law in Britain than the
right to freedom of religion for sure
right right a free freedom of speech the
right of
any of the rights that we enjoy in the
Constitution the right to self-defense
is the Gerdes all the American project
because it is about defending the
individual your property and your rights
and then of course there are practical
reasons why people loved guns in America
and it had more to do than just
philosophy it was because they had to
deal with when the Pilgrims landed for
instance right away they had yard long
arrows falling on them yet to deal with
the French they had to deal with the
Dutch they had to deal with other
communities there were scores of
practical purposes why people had guns
obviously so that under under that is
the foundational reason for the Second
Amendment and everyone understood that
militias were made up of individuals
that they weren't run from the top down
but from the bottom up for communities
who were thousands of miles away from
their own governments that would be able
to protect them I want to give you one
quote from John Adams who in 1717
seventy rather bravely defended in court
one of the British soldiers who fired
into a mob of Americans Boston Massacre
he at the time argued that everyone
every every private person is authorized
to arm himself person and on the
strength of his own authority and then
he pointed out that it that self-defense
was the primary canon of law of nature
the primary one so on revisionists say
that the founders never envisioned
individuals owning guns even soldiers
even soldiers who were hated in general
by the population had a right to defend
their person and that didn't change in
the 19th century the British even the
British who tried to confiscate weapons
that's what you know the Revolution had
almost broken out during the powder
scare which was before our Lexington and
Concord because they kept confiscating
weapons and ammunition even they never
made an argument that an individual
shouldn't be able to love to allow to
have a gun to protect himself or provide
for his family and also the British
instantly worried about the populace
because they were armed in a way that no
other nation that they oversaw no other
people that they ever saw were armed
there I have many quotes from British
leaders at the time writing back to
England kind of nervous that they were
trying to you know confiscate weapons
sort of questioning the practicality of
trying to do something like that and in
England I don't think they understood
that I have a quote from Richard Price
he was a defender of the colonial cause
in England he was Welsh and his quote
was every inhabitant has in his house as
part of his furniture a book on law and
government to enable him to understand
his civil rights and a musket to enable
him to defend those rights and a Bible
to enable him to understand and practice
his religion there was an English
visitor that same year who wrote back to
his wife and he wrote there is not a man
born in America that does not understand
the use of firearms it's almost the
first thing they purchase and take all
the new settlement to take all to all
the new settlements and cities you
scarcely find a lad of 12 years old who
is not gunning they were also recently
historians have done probate they've
gone through probate records of people
in Virginia and Maryland I just want to
give you a couple of examples of how
prevalent guns were in colonial times
one of them found that 62% of household
had at least one firearms firearm at the
time of death of the person in his will
and that to put that in context it's
more than books Bible swords or knives
and another one in Virginia 74% of
people had guns which was more than
tables furniture axes knives hoes which
matters because obviously tobacco was a
big crowd
it's also worth noting throughout the
19th century there was still not a
single person who challenged the
individual right of a person to earn on
firearms there's no such case the
Supreme Court never took it up and
there's no record of anyone even making
an argument against it the Joseph story
was on the Supreme Court the early part
of the 1800s said that
the right of citizens to keep and bear
arms had just leap has justly been
considered as the Palladium of the
liberties of the Republic since it
offers a strong moral check against
arbitrary power power of rulers that is
the core of the second amendment
defending ourselves from tyranny as well
as our person personal you know property
contemporary liberals view that kind of
language as treasonous in a way if you
tell them well I'd like a gun because
you never know when the government is
going to come take my stuff they laugh
at you and I think that is a very narrow
view of history I have to typically my
my response to that is that simply
because you don't need a right this
moment for a particular purpose doesn't
mean that that right doesn't need to be
fostered and protected for instance the
First Amendment just because I sit in my
room and never talk to anyone doesn't
mean that it's not an important right
the Second Amendment is something that
needs to protect it even if you don't
own a gun and when you undermine that
right and how you view that right at
least in my estimation tells us a lot
and I'm not talking about just trying to
ban bum socks or some sort of safety
regulation but how you view the Second
Amendment in itself tells us a lot about
how you view individual freedom in
general if you don't believe a person if
you believe a person should always have
to rely on the state to defend him is
family and his property maybe you don't
get what the Constitution is about and
it is true and the revisionists argument
about this is that in the in the 1800s
when the Industrial Revolution came in
guns became cheaper and more and easier
to buy and prevalent that is when gun
culture first took hold in America I
think I've just gone through some
reasons why that's not true but what is
true is that he became even more
prevalent it was even easier to buy a
gun and we're talking about an era where
the the first revolver was invented the
breech-loading rifle the first machine
guns a crank machine gun and later even
more powerful ones and still not anyone
not anyone challenged the right the
First Amendment right as an individual
right even with those sorts of powerful
weapons I'm during the Civil War all
these things made by
by cult and others were used on the
battlefield and yet no one thought to
question it conical bullets as well it's
also worth mentioning at this point that
when we talk about the history of gun
everyone typically focuses on the
philosophical angles of it but gun
makers were some of the leading
inventors engineers men of Commerce
during the during the first Industrial
Revolution Sam Colt was using
interchangeable parts long before Henry
Ford was you know he they were making
incredible weapons coming up with
incredible ideas changing the way the
Americans could could view the world but
also how they could populate the West
turning a one-man into an army of six a
Sam Colt said it was a big reason why
people could keep forging westwards
which they had done from the beginning I
would stress though that not everyone
and not all Americans benefited from
this right early there were occasionally
gun control laws typically to try to
subjugate some people Catholics versed
maybe or you know Indians obviously and
certainly African Americans and for that
matter for many blacks who live in urban
areas today their rights are still being
taken away from them but I would just
give you a few examples because some of
the greatest arguments for the Second
Amendment I think were made by civil
rights leaders after the Civil War right
after the Civil War or during the Civil
War Frederick Douglass when the Fugitive
Slave Act of 1850 was passed said that
the best remedy would be a good revolver
steady hand and it's a determination to
shoot down any man attempting kidnapping
I doubt any modern liberal would call
that treasonous of him to say right so
it's important to put that in context
and also we're talking a lot a lot about
the 14th amendment today but when Jacob
Howard introduced the 14th amendment to
ensure that blacks and the South could
have their constitutional rights
protected he noted that it that it was
something that would ensure the personal
rights guaranteed secured by the first
eight amendments of the Constitution he
called them all individual rights and he
specifically spoke about the right to
bear arms
it was it was important it was an
individual right and it was it was still
idealized in the way that the founders
had idealized it I to be Wells in fact
said that every afro-american should
ponder well that Winchester rifle should
have a place of honor in every black
home it's important to make those kinds
to - to show I think through - to
populations I might think differently
about guns that they have a history as
well it's very important with firearms
in America another argument I hear quite
often I just want to mention it because
Nicholas Kristof of the New York Times
mentioned it today in his piece is that
the revisionist do this thing where they
go through the history of the United
States pick out every little gun control
measure that every municipality ever
passed and like put it into a big
amorphous book and then say look
Americans have always been for gun
control it's not it's not a serious
argument and one of the one of the the
ones they love to talk about is the Old
West dot city there was a sign that said
leave your guns here before you know
entering or something to that nature I
did a lot of research on this in the Old
West on in gun violence which was much
lower than than obviously movies seem to
portray there were places in America
where you were asked to hand over your
gun before going to a red-light district
filled with saloons and [ __ ] houses and
things of that nature but it would bend
beyond the imagination of anyone
involved in that to say to think that
they would ever have to ask the state
permission to have a gun they
voluntarily handed over their guns did
whatever they did and on the way out got
their guns back there is nothing and
there is no law passed certainly in a
federal level but not on a state level
either that that would force an American
citizen to ask permission to have a gun
or that would even
tell them how many guns they could have
or what sorts of guns they could have
that did not exist until the 1930s it
wasn't until the early 1900s in the 30s
because a bunch of psychopaths were
driving around you know shooting up
banks with fully automatic machine guns
and that people start to change their
perception of guns the Tommy gun changed
the way people thought about guns it was
a powerful weapon that you could carry
around and you know it could shoot
hundreds of rounds in a minute even
though even that was overdone the tommy
gun wasn't it was rarely used in
criminality though it was so that that
sort of happened and then there was a
huge reaction to that in the 5th 40s and
50s people coming back from world war ii
that was a very hunting you know we're
big on hunting and sort of gun sports
and that was there was this huge surge
in ownership of guns after the 30s and
then in the 60s is when you had sort of
criminality run rampant starting in
around 1965 and that is when the modern
gun debate became framed in the way that
we see it now half the population and
many people who didn't have a history
with guns many people from other
countries and in urban areas that never
had guns were decided that they didn't
want to be robbed and and and deal with
guns so they wanted laws that you know
controlled who had them and how many
they had and wanted to get them off the
street and the other half of the nation
said we need guns to protect ourselves
from these criminals so that's when the
NRA in the 70s had their big famous
split in Cincinnati in 1977 where they
had to decide if they were going to be a
second Amendment advocacy group or more
a hobbyist hunting organization and they
there was sort of a bit of a coup and
they became an organization for the
Second Amendment though they still did
all the things they did before and you
know everyone including the Kristof and
others like to point out that this is
when the radicals took over but that of
course isn't true the membership from
1977
1983 of the NRA doubled it became much
more popular than was before and just
simply because they have a different
focus didn't mean that the original
people who were members didn't believe
in the same sorts of things I went
through tons of old American rifle the
official magazine of the NRA rifle
magazines from the 50s and 40s and there
were plenty of pro-second amendment
folks as a part of it but still that's
the framework for the modern debate and
through these so that you have that
framework it's on a very local level but
there's still no federal laws on 1968
there was a federal lawn in 1930s but
none of them banned any sorts of guns
really just how you could use them what
kind of you know what kind of taxes do
you need to pay to have them there was
no banning of guns Nicholas Kristof did
you mentioning him because he's serving
capsulated all the bad arguments about
this said that handguns were almost
banned in 1934 that's just a fantasy the
handguns weren't banned the NRA never
proposed anything like that or supported
anything like that in 1934 the first gun
control laws put a tax on tommy guns
said that you in a court case said that
you could regulate how long a shotgun
barrel was things of that nature
but by the 1970s and 80s you had more
laws in 1986 I think it was they banned
in really ban it but it became very hard
to have a fully automatic weapon before
that time there was no ban on any sort
of gun you could buy any gun you wanted
basically whenever you wanted in except
in certain cities like New York what
they don't like to talk about is that
the prevalence so crime peaked somewhere
in the early 90s and then since then
crime has gone down from many many
societal reasons but they don't like to
mention is that gun ownership also
boomed again from the 90s till recently
gun ownership was basically up but many
people had bought more powerful guns
more guns and yet crime continued to
fall there was no correlation between
more guns and more crime now unlike some
others
whoo look at these numbers and say that
there is a correlation more guns means
less crime I'm not so sure that's
exactly why crime fell in cities I think
gentrification a lot of other factors go
into that but still and yet it should be
mentioned up till this time there was
almost no case law no Supreme Court
cases very few that actually dealt with
the with the the question of collective
rights or individual rights until Heller
where I'm sure most of you or all of you
know sort of codified the individual
right to your individual right the real
purpose of the Second Amendment and even
though I have to say as a practical
concern it don't really and hasn't
changed my life much in Maryland it's
still almost impossible you know it's
very difficult to get a gun in many
places or in Washington DC I'm sure so
but still it matters because it matters
that we talk about our constitutional
rights in the correct way so you know
one of the just one of the bigger
arguments that people make about gun
ownership in this country and have from
the beginning and from the beginning of
this modern debate was that the founders
had never foreseen us using such
powerful weapons like an ar-15 which
isn't as powerful as it looks maybe but
still and obviously the answer to that
and Scully answered it as well is that
is they didn't vision the internet
either perhaps or they didn't envision
you know the ways that our privacy was
going to be undermined that doesn't mean
that the core natural right doesn't
remain the same it's also false of
course because as we as I noted in the
early 18th century they're already more
powerful guns and no one brought up that
argument but in any event although
that's short that's just the history of
the debate over over the Second
Amendment and I think it's important to
understand that even in this partisan
time where I think the gun rights issue
will be more partisan which it wasn't
really that partisan before they were it
was more of a rural versus urban thing
but now everything has become partisan
in a way is that the Second Amendment to
me at least the most important the first
freedom simply because all the others
are protected by
secondly because as I mentioned I think
it's tells us a lot about how you view
the Constitution but thirdly I think
when people talk about religious culture
in this country or speech culture or
whatever culture gun culture is just as
important to our existence the history
of gun culture is just as important to
our existence and when and when they try
to revise that history and in a sort of
an Orwellian way change it to to comport
with their contemporary arguments about
guns we can't let them do that and
history is the you know it's very
important to make sure that we preserve
the history and a lot of gun owners and
a lot of gun folks or gun nuts out there
are very into their weapons and they
will read a giant book on how an ar-15
works or how their Glock works but I
think that it's important for them to
make the argument in a broader way and
to talk about guns as it relates to
American history as a whole and that's
why I wrote the book and hopefully I can
put a little dent into that argument as
well and moving forward so those are my
comments and I just I thought it would
be nice if we have some questions and we
could talk about what you guys think
[Music]
I think that the founders were pretty
smart folks and that they understood
that the technology was moving forward
and things would evolve in in there was
a there was an air gun for instance that
was probably taken or was taken by Lewis
and Clark who do you you know who the
founders knew of them and knew of this
gun and it's shot I think around you
know 70 times without reloading they
understood that guns would be more
powerful in fact I think they probably
understood or thought that people should
have the guns that the military had in
fact you know standing armies were a big
point of debate between many of them so
yes hi what would be the effects of a
blanket gun ban so again the effects of
a blanket gun ban remains very well norm
and every buyback program what's not a
plausible scenario really because there
are 400 million guns probably out there
more or less what would happen if the
government went out and confiscated
those guns I imagine there would be some
sort of violent civil war but perhaps
people would hand them over who were
law-abiding and criminals wouldn't in
crime would rise I mean I guess I think
that that that would be the outcome now
even if you wanted to you know a lot of
people want to ban so after parked the
Parkland shooting horrific shooting they
had a CNN you know town-hall thing and
all the people were cheering when
someone said they wanted to ban
semi-automatic weapons now it could be
that they don't understand the
difference between a semi-automatic
weapon and an automatic weapon but to
ban semi-automatic weapons would take
literally the US army to go into Montana
would probably take them years just to
try to find all of them and then they'd
have to go state-by-state so it's not
really plausible that's why when we when
you debate these people and they say
things like that you know they want to
ban a certain kind of gun it's
incredibly popular like even an ar-15
it's just not a it's just not going to
happen
so last week in the Federalist podcast
you mentioned you're less concerned
about the Second Amendment compared to
the other amendments currently what do
you see is the threats the Second
Amendment what's the most likely way
that that our gun rights could be eroded
right now yeah my point was merely I
think that the first fourth fifth tenth
amendments are in bigger trouble in the
second simply because of the physical
nature of a gun and the way that people
own them the threat will be in my
opinion is that people well local level
there'll be threats there'll be taxes on
ammunition and there'll be things of
that nature
I am very pro-gun but I think maybe gun
people overreact sometimes when there's
you know something going on I don't mind
that as a political concern but I think
the big threat is that there will be
more younger people will not services so
I mentioned hunting before and hunting
is not that popular anymore so a lot of
the guns that people owned and gave
their kids it was about hunting that
doesn't happen anymore so I think
culturally it will it will be there a
more of a divide between people people
live in rural areas and people who live
maybe in suburban areas so I think the
guns will become somewhat less popular
moving forward that's what what I see is
a threat to gun culture I don't know
about the Second Amendment yeah hello
Jacob James rich Reason Foundation and
whenever I'm discussing guns with people
who are not for them unlike me I usually
bring up the best-case scenario we press
a magic button and whatever gun you want
to disappear does and I think that if we
did that there probably would be less
mass shootings even though I don't
particularly want to get rid of guns so
how do we as gun owners address the fact
that since they exist violence is going
to exist but having them in general is
still worth it in the long run it might
be boarding the car if you did if you
what what I said so what are you saying
so if you push a button and get rid of a
gun we're gonna have less mass shooting
was why well if you if we got rid of all
semi-automatic weapons in this country
automatically I would argue that the
show
term consequence of that would be that
would be much harder to commit mass
shootings yeah yeah I mean but yeah I
mean I think that if you could ensure
somehow that those semi-automatics would
be taking it taken out of the hands of
people who are insane racist
anti-semitic and criminal then yeah we
could if there was some magic button but
that doesn't happen right so so I can't
really concede even that point to you I
think so I don't underst so if it's not
a plausible thing why even debate it I
guess if I can if we can make the point
that having these weapons amid the
troubles that come with them it's still
worth it that's gonna make parts and I
try to make that oh yeah yeah I mean I I
wrote a book called nanny state and I
would argue on on the radio this is your
ten years ago you know and I would argue
well if someone wants to eat fatty foods
and smoke and drink every day it's none
of your business we you know they're
there with freedom comes a level of
responsibility but also a level of
danger I think that that's part of gun
ownership as well and you can either be
free or not so that's an argument in
seven you know in the 1770s that I think
would have been excellent to make too
but now you know it is what it is so I'm
trying to remember so I think
semi-automatics for sure or them you
know sell more than revolvers and
shotguns in this country so it's just a
popular gun it's in common use these
shootings we can't ignore them obviously
they're they're horrific and and people
pick up guns and do them another thing I
just wanted to mention I often make the
argument well look homicides gun
homicides are way down even school
shootings are down even mass shootings
are down it doesn't really matter right
people don't think you know I'm always
telling people you have the best life
ever why you so upset why is everyone so
upset this is the greatest time in
history people viewed the world through
the context of their own time they don't
really care what happened in the how bad
it was in eighteen hundreds I think with
guns it's similar just because there's
fewer crimes now it's not really a way
to convince them to be pro-gun
even though I think it's a fine point to
make yeah hey feeding off of your
discussion about we don't just relying
upon the government to protect us you
know you look at the black lives matter
movement there are actually some real
concerns about how police handle the
situation with in black communities but
if you go further back when you see even
more sincere abuses saying the
post-civil war period where you actually
had police forces that were confiscating
guns of African Americans and so that
they wouldn't be able to protect
themselves and sometimes being
participants in the terrorizing of black
people particularly in states like
Louisiana and some other states in the
south you and feeding off of the
Frederick Douglass quote you see that
that individual right really has
precedence over what what we would
expect of a police force that could go
awry in certain places is that not a
significant way to also help discuss and
put light on this issue particularly in
inner cities large metropolitan areas I
I don't know I make that argument quite
often I probably not convincing
convincing enough but it's an argument I
think that should be made I was on the
reason podcast actually with Nick
Gillespie and we were talking about the
Black Panthers in the 60s and Ice not
saying that you know they were always
good people for the you know part of the
Black Panthers in the Bay Area but
sometimes they made really great
arguments about the Second Amendment and
the reason why they should be able to
have guns now I'm not sure that they
were I think that they were exaggerating
how the police forces were you know
acting towards them but they made some
incredibly strong arguments but the
problem is again I think everything is
so partisan it's very hard to get you
know everyone is so sort of there's no
real movement I think on issues anymore
that at least that's my perception and I
feel like guns are one of those issues
where Democrats who represent most
minority communities simply don't move
and I'll give you another example of
that I'm Jewish right
I've lived in Israel twice where we're
18 and 17 year-olds walk around with
fully automatic weapons go to bars with
them it's a weird thing to see when you
first go there there's no real mass
shootings though it probably happens
occasionally Jewish people should be the
most Pro Second Amendment group in the
world considering their history that
doesn't mean they could stop the
Holocaust but it doesn't mean that it
wouldn't be so easy right partisans
fought in world war ii there's many
examples and you saw what happened the
other day it's horrific and Donald Trump
mentioned that maybe if there had been a
guard that would have been less and
everyone went berserk like that's some
absurd thing we can't arm Americans and
I keep saying you don't arm Americans
Americans get to arm themselves that's
what's in the Constitution and but yet I
grew up in a Jewish community everyone
was anti-gun I have family and people I
know where I grew up with and they're
all really anti-gun and they didn't grow
up in that culture and they don't care
to understand it and unless they move to
Israel then they understand it I
remember being on a bus this is when you
could go between to the old city and go
to the Arab sector and some one kid came
up and threw a rock at the window and
it's Plexiglas but the rock was coming
right at me by rock I mean like a giant
brick and it bounces off and an old
rabbi type next to me he just takes out
like a ninety browning 1911 you know
he's ready and it's a little scary but
you know I felt a little bit kind of
safe too and as well so yeah
well thank you Steve winters could you
say a little bit more you touched on
this in several different ways for
instance you talked about the people
coming home from World War two and of
course they had a lot of experience with
guns out on the battlefields it's over
and so on I had the opportunity to be a
civilian contractor with the US military
in the 80s of the nineteen so quite a
bit of action and what I'm trying to
focus on is it's the connection between
the idea the the old idea the armed
citizenry in other words we don't really
want to just have a special class of
people who are the killers and that's
the military that's at least that's not
the old concept but for example at least
when I was with the Marines I was
surprised to find that and this was the
world men at the moment at that time
that the Marines actually slept with
their guns the rifles and they also were
told to give them a female name because
the argument was this is as close to you
as anybody who's a real person is ever
going to get and you have to treat it
that way now I would say that's a gun
culture so the idea that that we would
remove the whole gun culture from the
culture at large and yet have this
massive military engagement over the
years and somehow have an extreme gun
culture after a fashion in in the
military it seems like a contradiction
you want you want those two to be
complementary not contradictory right
also you make you make a good point that
I didn't mention is that when in World
War two when there was a draft and
people men went to the army and they all
dealt with weapons and had guns in their
hands ate em once powerful weapon that
they love and romanticized in a way and
it was a very you know I I wrote a piece
and because I'm on the internet and the
thing you do is your number it's things
like the five best guns ever account you
know it's get hits and I did that I
didn't put the m1 garand in there and I
was just you know killed for it
but people will come home and they in
the 40s they came home and there and
there was a booming gun ownership they
want it to be hunting they gave it to
their you know they gave it guns to
their kid
and they weren't I think because when
you handle a gun and you know how to
work with a gun and you realize how
powerful it is and what it can do and
those men saw things that you know that
were horrible I think that you respected
in a way that maybe the normal people
who never handle a gun wouldn't and I
like I didn't fire a gun until I was in
my 30s and it was exhilarating and and
and and the people I met were very
safety conscious and and you know there
were nothing like the slack-jawed yokels
that you see you know them depicted as
so I think that that part's important
and of course your other point that we
shouldn't just have trained killers and
then everyone else is very important and
it's very it's a very American idea you
know just because of the size of the
place and the ideals that people brought
here and in the reality around them as
the country grew and as they kept
pushing out west these Western towns
people were far away from any real
government and they all had guns to
protect themselves it's just sort of
engrained in the idea of America I think
so it's a good point yeah I was working
if you could talk about the Supreme
Court case US v Miller both supporters
and opponents of gun control seem to
think this decision kind of reinforces
their views everyone thinks that
decision reinforces their views I'm not
a lawyer but the decision itself and
Scalia talks about this was pretty
clearly very narrowly about how the
government had a hat could regulate how
certain guns worked specifically a
shotgun that was sawed off so that the
person could conceal it I think there
was another component to Miller then I'm
forgetting it was kind of a setup by the
way Miller there was it was a FDR was
trying to have passed the and his
Congress had passed the National
Firearms Act 1934 and I believe they
some court you know someone challenged
the challenge the law and the on purpose
to bring it up to Supreme Court went all
the way up there I don't even think that
Miller had any lawyers show up I think
to make their arguments if I remember
correct
but I'm not a lawyer but from from from
the lawyers that I trust you know and
Scalia's thus in the hello decisions
that you know stated that that was about
government being able to regulate
certain kinds of guns not banning guns
that were in common use and not banning
complete you know categories of weapons
merely because they had scary names or
the aesthetics weren't pleasing to
people or scared them but there's a good
book on that by Aikido writer I don't
remember the name of it but I remember
the name of the author owning a gun but
carrying a gun you know you watch all
these westerns the cold is changing
everything is visible so what what's the
history there well handguns until the
revolver were not as popular obviously
as muskets and rifles and even rifles
were less popular than made out of in
movies and in literature and 1800's or
many books about the Kentucky rifle
which is an amazing gun at the time gave
you really three hundred yards of 250
yards of shooting where as a musket
maybe give you 50 yards but handguns
were for dueling
or you know they were for gentlemen and
then they start to build the small
pepper gun and derringers things of that
nature and obviously revolvers and
because Sam Colt and others who
industrialized the making of guns people
it was much cheaper and people could
carry them around and in the West they
did carry them around they didn't always
carry them around in the way that they
do in the movies most of the pictures of
the Old West people have them tucked
into their pants or belts they don't
have fancy holsters I doubt there are
probably more thousands of more people
killed in the western movies and were in
the actual West I have some numbers
about that in the book I think it's
pretty interesting about how criminality
wasn't really that high when everyone
has a gun or most people have guns
you're a little careful about you know
pulling your own gun most of the famous
sort of anti heroes and guns
as we talked about we're really
basically Psychopaths and killers and
very rarely did they duel you know at
dawn or whatever typically it was just a
fight broke out they took out their gun
and shot someone in the head though Wild
Bill Hickok's a really interesting guy
and he sort of invented the gun slinger
and then it became a huge you know huge
sort of trend in the West to read those
books about gun fighters and stuff in
that myth that's mote a lot of mythology
and I think we still live with it but
yeah I think people many men people you
know from the gold rush and thing like
that that carried Remington's and Colts
these were giant you know Colt had a
giant company and he made it was one of
the richest men in America he even
opened a factory in England at one point
he was he was maybe the first
industrialist to go to Europe and open a
factory it didn't work out because he
said the work ethic of the English was
terrible and he came back but but he's
just this amazing character and I you
know I'd love to talk about these guys
at John Browning as well he's just a
genius and and I want to just mention
this too about all these gun makers and
you can talk go through the makers of
the Kentucky rifle all the way today
ar-15 in Eugene stoner they're all
autodidact they all taught themselves
they're all tinker's they're very
American characters none of them were
you know engineers or you know work
meaning me and go to school to be
engineers they were all self-made men
and I think I think their stories are
really incredible in America very
American
as you can see I'd much rather talk
about Sam Colt and stuff like that than
the politics of guns you know it's
exciting and I think people don't really
know that history XP just following up
the previous question and your answer do
people have to have certain culture or
code of honor
to have so many gun in societies and I'm
from Pakistan and you know the part of
Pakistan where this Taliban or
Mujahideen movement came from if it's a
code of honor
you would have many people who have gone
on their shoulder but you know they are
not out of control they're not they are
not but in this state it's very
different
because people have so many rights I
could have killed 10 people but still
are minnows and sadness unless proven
guilty and they're so difficult
sometimes to prove guilty in the court
because you can have a very competent
lawyer about my particular question
about this culture thing most mass mass
murder in the state are done by white
people so the prevalence of gun has
something to do with race or it has to
do with the NRA because it's very very
powerful organization because I'm sure
that if this problem was among African
American society would push more to Bank
on then the you're doing right now
Thanks well I mean I guess I would just
push back immediately uh you know about
the N are being NRA being powerful in
the way that maybe maybe not you
describe it but it's generally described
as if it lit as if they have in their
basement sort of a money-making machine
that allows them to just be powerful on
their own no a lot of people support the
Second Amendment and that's why they
have a say and they're powerful I I
don't I don't think it's a racial thing
at all but I do think that it's a
cultural thing in a way I think Second
Amendment doesn't work without all the
other freedoms and all the other ways
that Americans were you know I'm saying
I think it all works together it's it's
a holistic Constitution is holistic the
second amendments my one of the most
important parts of it in my opinion but
still works together it's about the
people who are there and being an
American obviously isn't about what you
color your skin it's about the ideas and
and and and the culture around you so I
don't think it's a racial thing I don't
have answers to the why someone walks
into a into a place and starts shooting
people but it's certainly not unique to
America I mean you have in Norway you
have one of the worst mass killings like
that ever in the Taliban I have to say
aren't always that peaceful and there
are many groups in the Middle East that
use weapons to to kill innocent
civilians as well so I don't think it's
an American problem I think what happens
here is that when you do have someone
who's not right or is politically
motivated it is easier sometimes to get
a weapon in the United States than is
and let's say Europe and then
bad things happen and we discussed that
unfortunately in some sense a price of
freedom sometimes so I don't want a bank
gun so I'm not sure I can even answer
the part about the NRA very well a few
questions ago in the midst of a longer
answer you asserted quote-unquote mass
shootings are down define what a mass
shooting is what is the time horizon
that you're using to make that assertion
and what is the source data that
buttresses that I don't have that all
here but I can I can I've written about
it and I it's online I would say I think
that the the data I had was from the
1999 the early 90s till now on mass
shootings where maybe if it goes farther
back I'm not sure John Stossel actually
also did something I think in reason
about this
there are many deaf and there's no the
definition of mass shooting depends on
who you're talking to for instance I saw
Vox had a definition where if you were
with like within a mile of a school and
you shot a gun that was considered a
school shooting right so it's very
diverting is all different I think it's
three people are shot at or something or
maybe it was four so I don't I don't
have that right in front of me but I've
written about it and I can if you give
me your card or whatever I can send you
those links yeah and it might be
disputed I mean there might be debate
about it I haven't seen anyone dispute
the numbers I saw but hi
so I'm from New York as well so I know
what it is to grow up in a city where
guns aren't that popular you could just
talk about your personal journey of
going from not growing up in a gun
culture to having an appreciation for it
because I noticed that supporters always
tend to argue facts and history but our
opponents always seem to argue emotion
so I'd love to know more about your
emotions and what you've much of a share
but I will tell you a story a personal
vote you're welcome so my dad and my mom
defect
from communist Hungary my dad was there
for the 1956 revolution and he saw I
think guns in a different light than
most of our neighbors right in a Jewish
community I grew up in then my dad had a
store a little jewelry store on Long
Island and that store and I was there I
was 11 years old and three guys came in
with guns and robbed it and took all his
stuff destroyed his business basically
because he had built it up after many
years and he what he decided went a
little overboard he got a Doberman glass
windows people had to ask to come in and
Buzz him in and he got a gun or he
wanted to get a gun and he was in New
York and you know and go to 47th Street
it's where all the jewelry places were
and you'd have to carry you know
diamonds or whatever on the subway he
wanted a gun to protect himself and it
was so hard to get a gun it took him I
don't know how long but more than a year
or more
he had to you know you have to have his
friends sign for him yet so yeah I
forgot what he had to go through but I
was just a kid I can't pretend I was
like serious about these things but you
know the Second Amendment I says you can
have a gun it's right there and yet they
wouldn't let my dad who is not a
criminal who has a business protect
himself his family and his property so
probably that changed my mind I don't
know if that's sort of a retroactive way
for me to say I did but I've always been
very libertarian less so lately but I've
grew up libertarian and so the
Constitution matter to me and I saw what
it said and it became very ideological
for me and it wasn't until I moved to
Denver though that I really met people
who were gone people and I was a little
bit nervous about them right it's their
crazy gun nuts but I noticed that like I
said before they were wonderful people
they were very very focused on safety
they loved to tinker with the guns and
build the guns and they never threatened
anyone with them they took it very
seriously and not changed my mind about
them too and then I became curious about
the history so I guess that would be the
sort of short story of the journey
whenever there is a mass shooting event
or something like that with well with
almost any other sort of politically
or something there's going to be horse
trading around the edges there's going
to and and but this is not one of them
you never after a mass shooting have
someone say look we really need to ban
30 round magazines I really need to put
a stop to bump stocks so we'll grant
your side you know the right for you
know concealed carry reciprocity or
something like that in exchange for this
and this really seems like the one issue
in American politics where neither side
is willing to yield any ground at all is
that just a factor of fundraising or do
people make a impossible stand and get a
lot of money and political support that
and they don't have to carry out you
know they don't have to follow through
on it or is there something just there's
two sides and positions are so
incompatible they can never never make
never do any actual politics and horse
trading on the issues it's a really good
question I'm not sure I would say that a
lot of it does have to do with
fundraising and it's sort of a very
emotional issue for people so it's
probably very powerful as a as a
campaign tool and obviously we're
constantly in election outs
oh wait everyone's just running all the
time so I think that's part of it I also
think that you know I'll try to be fair
here I think that a lot of gun people
and I think they have some reason for
this don't believe that there's just
sort of an increment there's an
incremental ISM about gun control where
every time you give them something
they're gonna want something more in the
next minute so they don't want to yield
any more a ground and on the other side
frankly I think that there's a there's a
lack of understanding about what guns
are quite often when you see like
assault rifle bans you know it's all
about aesthetics never real you know it
doesn't ever really seem to it always
seems to inhibit the law-abiding citizen
from having a gun rather than go after
why a shooting happened in any kind of
real way so I mean list that's my
perception so I think that those are
some of the factors and quite quite
honestly another factor simply is the
way just we are right now I mean think
of another entry like immigration there
could be plenty of horse trading going
on an immigration but no one wants to do
it because they're activist bases won't
give an inch and they want to be elected
so I just think that's sort of the I
just think that's just sort of the
reality of the day
and hopefully hopefully I mean you know
hopefully we can get over pointed out it
but maybe no thank you
all right
[Applause]